The general good experience.
Even back then,
I saw where change was trying to take place in the industry and they
wasn't gone loud. I call it a conspiracy.
I saw it a conspiracy taking place where they wasn't going to allow any more
masterpiece cash, money. Uh, uh,
Irv got independent independence. They would like shutting that door.
So, you know, in my mind, I'm like, okay, I see the mood they make.
And let me counter this and create another Avenue for the youth to
come in after us. And unfortunately, uh, I think,
uh, they witnessed the same thing and they hit murder, Inc,
which is Irv Gotti company distraught. It, they hit shook night there for row.
We know what happened with that. And they came at me in a massive way,
you know,
all the way up to the point where they put a man on me that killed eight
people. And I really believe, you know,
he was trying to kill me.
And when you say they put a man on you, like in what way.
They assigned a guy by the name of Schumacher, you know,
on me to arrest me to whatever he was
supposed to do. But he sent death threats at me.
And here's a man that killed eight people. You know, I hired the,
since they was investigating me,
I decided to hire an investigator to investigate them.
And that's when I found out this guy killed all of those people. You know,
I brought the investigating report.
So you can look at it if you choose to showed me outside. So, you know,
this was a real life situation that people may hear and
thank, you know, this is not true,
but he is confirmation of how true it was in 1999. You know,
I reported this with the help of Congresswoman Maxine waters,
Janet Reno,
because they intervene on my behalf because they saw what was
happening. And of course we, they had a, uh, what you call it,
a congressional hearing on me,
all of this is public information on congressional hearing where the
DEA and, you know,
it reminded me of the time when Clarence Thomas was,
uh, being, uh, a hearing was taking place over his harassment or something.
Then all of those people, Democrat and Republicans was around,
you know what I mean, had him in a circle.
So this is the conversation they was having concerning me, James Prince.
And I'm watching this, you know, on, uh, um, on video.
I'm not invited,
but I'm watching them have this conversation about me or about the congressional
hearing. And, uh, I'm just like, wow, you know, these people want pretty bad,
but a long story short, you know,
they were able to speak up on my behalf and you know,
which ultimately, Oh, it's so many connections to this.
Cause even Al Gore, you know,
came in a portrait where they tried to sit me up at my church with
Al Gore, Al Gore came to visit my church. You know,
which when you running for president,
you visit a lot of black churches and stuff like that.
And my pastor wanted me to meet Al Gore that day.
So when I pull up, you know, I was married at the time. You know,
I told my wife, I say,
all these people ain't here with the president because I was watching body
language. You know, I saw a black,
black glasses kinda looking my direction. And she said, Oh, come on, boy,
you been leery. You know, people not thinking about you or whatever.
So I went and heard the sermon and before the sermon was over,
I say, let's go. Normally I hang around and socialize. And of course,
pastor wanted me to meet Al Gore. I decided to leave.
And shortly after the Dallas newspaper came
out with, uh, a story in all of this, you can confirm and look it up.
James Prince donated a quarter million dollars to Al
Gore at the church to stop an investigation on him.
Oh man. Just a bunch of BS. Unbelievable. You know what I mean?
So I was being set on news. Oh yeah. It's documented.
So they created this fake story to make you look bad
and they printed it in the news. So it had to be coordinated at the very top.
Oh yeah. Wow. Yeah.
What was that like to know they were conspiring against you like that, you know,
first of all, you had to feel like, Oh, I must've made it. Well.
I didn't quite feel that I had made. I felt like they wanted to hit me.
You know, because like these,
this guy one night I left my office and a
DPS officer stopped me.
He got behind me on the streets when I left out of the office,
but he stopped me on the freeway. And it was the first time I was stopped.
One time to be told, to go and stop again.
So he stopped me on the freeway and told me to go and pull in the McDonald's
parking lot. So I say, Oh, okay.
So as I exit the freeway and looked over in the McDonald's parking lot and it
was dark and I saw Kara, uh,
cherry key Jeep green and a Cutlass,
and it was a dog. So I'm like, nah,
I'm not pulling in that dog. So I kind of told him,
I'm going to pull in the shell station where the lights were so up and I could
hear him in the back, poor over on his, on his thing,
make a right. I'm like, I'm going to go over here.
So I went over there and the light,
I had some guys behind me following me because they had been sending me threats.
So I'm not stupid. So I understood that, you know,
I need to cover myself until I make it home. And uh,
when I pulled over, you know, the officer got out and he said,
why you didn't pull over? Like I told you, I say, sir,
I didn't want you to think I was trying to hurt you in that dark.
And I didn't want to think you was trying to hurt me. What's the prop,
uh, what, where you were swerving? I say, no,
I say you got the wrong man. I don't drink. I don't smoke.
What no swerving going on with me. Well, uh, where are your guns?
Right? How do he even know I have guns?
I gave him my gun license. Well, how you know, I have gone.
I haven't even given you my license. So I gave him my license, say my hand,
hands on the steering wheel. My guns are under my seat. Well,
we'll get out the car, you know? And I say, okay,
I don't have a problem with that. How much money you have?
I say, okay, you want to borrow some money? Or somebody asked me about my money.
So he told me, so I went back there and um,
he went and searching my car. You know, he in there,
I see him like moving around with things, but he went on the passenger side.
So I walk around. I say, man, why are you violating my rights search in my car?
And he jumped it back. I'm looking for the gun. I said,
I told you where the guns are. Clearly, you then pass them up.
You got my clips out. So anyway,
he came back and I could see him make an eye contact with the call with the
people across the street.
And eventually one of them drove over and this was an officer
by the name of Chad Scott.
He had like black paint on his eyes and an army fatigue
type of a uniform and him, and also,
you know, translated some words. And he came back to me and say, okay,
you free to go and gave me a warning ticket, you know, a warning ticket.
And it was then when I got home,
I realized a bullet or two was missing. So red flags like. Yeah.
Like went up. I'm like, why would they keep one of my bullets?
Why were they trying to pull me in the dog? This was before I knew,
you know, Schumacher had killed eight people. You know what I mean?
So, you know, I went home and that really caused me to, uh, you know,
want to protect myself and want to document why I wanted to protect
myself.
It's so bizarre that they would take bullets because without the rifling.
From your particular gun, like all it's establishing is the same round you use.
Right? It doesn't mean.
Yeah, I did not. It's weird. You know, I just counted them. And then.
When you said that they were threatening, you like death threats,
like what kind of death, how were you receiving these.
What they were doing? And it's in the investigative report.
People that worked for me, you know,
I had a street team that would promote my Rutgers in different clubs at night.
What they had done was jumped on a couple of guys. They pull them over,
they took them down to the station, strip them naked, you know, jumped on him,
took the jewelry, you know, all kinds of stuff and send messages,
let him know, you know, we're going to do this. We're going to do this.
Which eventually when I made my report,
they ended up finding the jewelry in different things that I reported
that, you know, I told them, these guys, you got road cops. I say,
y'all put a Hitman on me. You got two road cops.
That's doing this and doing that. And I'm in field in my life. You know,
I just want it to be known because if a situation take place and I come out
on top, then I don't want nobody to be mad at me. Right.
Because I'm going to protect myself. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
How long did this period of turmoil last?
Cause it seemed like that would be incredibly stressed.
Well, it went on for years, you know? Yeah.
Even before then they stopped me one night and they,
they planted a peel on me called ecstasy, you know,
and where they put it, they put it. Here's what happened.
I was in the back seat. First of all, the police stopped me.
And this was officer. I had a run in with,
with a pistol case and I beat the pills to case. So he stopped me on, uh,
Richmond one night and he was like, well, how did you beat that case?
And he knew it was me because I had rap light on my license plate.
How did you be? I say, man, I don't really want to talk about that. I said,
I'm trying to go to a party. You know, why are you stopping me?
So made me get up, put me in the back of the police car, kept me there.
You know, talking to people for, you know, quite a long time.
And he decided to take me off the main street to a side
street.
And it was then where he took me out of one car and took me to another car
with two more young, uh, rookie officers.
And shortly after he came out with appeal in the back
of the first call, look what we have here. And I'm like,
you know, when I seen that taken place, I said to the two officers, I say, man,
I say, I've been in here. Y'all know he's nah, you're not trying to do that.
That's not look what we have here. Look what we have here.
And before I know it,
I was headed to the police station and they charged me with a
PO call ecstasy and I immediately got out of jail,
took a test, a drug test, took a lot of tech to tests just to prove,
you know, I had nothing to do with any of that.
So they tried to get me to cop out for probation and cop out. I'm like, no.
So the appeal changed from X, X, X,
a C to Drent transact, whatever that field is.
And it changed again, it was constantly changing as they test the pill.
And they was basically trying to get me the cop out for something.
And I wouldn't. And eventually the case was dismissed.
So how many years at all this go on for? You said it went on for years.
How many years?
I would say 10 years, 10 years of belt. I was a target.
Stay calm during that time. Cause that's gotta be incredibly stressed.
Yeah, it was, you know, because like in the hood where I'm from,
you have to survive the
guys that's in the hood because they trying to get you, you know,
wherever success is concerned,
they trying to get you and the police that's supposed to be protecting me.
The ones I'm paying all these taxes to have became a,
uh, uh, enemy where they was trying to get me. So it,
it was very stressful.
But after so long I became immune to it.
It's almost like, you know,
I had a made up mind because I was on a journey to break the poverty curse
where my family was concerned. That was my whole drive. I'm like,
I got to get my mother at his house that she always wanted. You know,
I come from the projects.
So I was dealing with a power that was greater than the power was from the
streets and from the police. And I was like, you know,
no weapon formed against me gonna prosper. So, you know, I had that mentality.
I wrapped it around spirituality. And you know, I say, if God be for me,
the world could be against me. And you know, it just became like a,
a lifestyle dealing with them. People.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.